forget to talking to you about next door
whatever who cares about DevOps so I'd
argue that the people who care about
DevOps are the kind of people say things
like this so except my machine I think
this is kind of useless right who cares
what works in your machine it's really
important that it works on the machine
that delivers value to your users so as
developers are used to like writing the
last line of code and something happens
you know some magic happens and then
eventually get the code is in the hands
of your users but like that whole magic
is quite complicated it can be very
complicated and hope to make it simpler
so here are the things that I want from
a develops tool chain or a pipeline and
for context so in a past life a few
years ago I was a small web dev that a
small web dev shop in in Australia and
we did we did the word DISA way that we
development right we we had product
sorry we had development servers that I
would association to and do development
and then when the time came to deploy
these changes to production I would sit
down make a meticulous like series of
notes and then we'd schedule the time
and when the time came I would search
into the production server do a git pull
and like very slowly try to like you
know do the database migrations or any
other like changes that I need to fix up
and this was less than ideal right and
even at the time I knew it was less than
ideal but it took me like a while to
like figure out why it was less than
ideal so here are the things that I want
now and I'll contrast them to the things
that I had then so I may I want my
deployment process to be automatic right
and this was not automatic I just very
much manual me like typing [ __ ] in and
anyway I would want one command that I
run that does a deployment for me
you know nothing else will do I want you
to be repeatable so if you're at a small
web dev shop then you only have to worry
about one server but otherwise you know
all of the time now you have to worry
about more than one server you have to
worry about multiple service so I want
my one deploy process to be just as
effective when I'm running it on file
servers or ten servers or 100 servers or
a thousand service sportin that's
repeatable I want to be idempotent and
this isn't strictly necessary but I
think it is very useful because it's
really frustrating when you're doing a
deploy to like have a 40-minute process
that ends
oh I didn't need to change anything
after all no good I wanted to be fast
enough that it notices that nothing has
changed and goes okay nothing to do here
I want to be reversible now this is
great because even if everything I get
everything else that I want I'm super
gonna make mistakes
right and when I've noticed that I made
a mistake I really want to be able to
roll back and go okay it's alright you
know we rolled back we can try this
again later when I fixed whatever
mistake that I made and I wanted to be
atomic and I want your atomic because I
don't want my users to see things that
are broken I want them to see one
working side and I want them to see a
slightly different working side or
service and yeah and this is not
something that I got because especially
because as I learned if you do a get
full it'll like change the files in
place and it's very possible to like
have users be like oh what's happening
and I was reading about this
specifically a little bit later and I
found out that apparently the best
practice with even get based deployment
is to have some other site that you do
get sorry another folder that you do it
get pulled to and then a symlink that
actually points that where you care
about and you swap the same link over
because the same link is one of the few
operations and unix that is guaranteed
to be atomic so I'll come back to that a
little bit later as I mention it now but
okay so let's start with the tiny web
service and I really like Haskell so I'm
gonna add this tiny web service in
Haskell this has this example is taken
straight from the scottie documentation
there there it is Scotty is a Haskell
library very much like flask for Python
it's very easy to make small web service
and this service does takes one
parameter here and it inserts it between
the words Scotty and me up and I call it
blank me up because I'm greater dynamic
things here's the years just easy just
details for awhile packaging the app so
these two files that I have and now we
can get started with the next stuff so
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna run
this command cobalt UNIX I come over
Haskell package manager so what this but
what this does is that it takes the the
Cobble description that I showed you
briefly above and turns it into annex
expression oh no hmm right my bad okay
it's done it's not really important what
the chord looks like if you're
interested I can shred you later oh I'm
sure we'll have time for questions so I
can run one come on hold next build
which should package and building
package the app
good what happens we want to run it
again it's already built it knows that
it's already built and it'll just give
me what it built last time and it
doesn't actually put anything in your
working directory except for this one
file called result and the result file
is it's a symlink to where the the
package actually lives in in the next
store so it's like it's like a directory
that only that only NYX can control that
stores the contents of everything that I
built and the only way that it interacts
with your actual like working directory
is through these same links so what
happens if I make a mistake in my app
what happens if I go and then I try to
build it again
oops but interestingly the results in
link is still there so so what Dix does
is it'll do the whole build and only
right at the end will actually swap over
the same link so if something was
working before it's not going to
suddenly break because you made a
mistake with your code so I'm going to
fix that and continue Oh
also you can run the the thing that we
just built so okay now that I've now
that I did that again this should this
shouldn't have to build again hmm Oh
weird okay I think my vim config puts
like files that yeah it's really
frustrating pull files in in places that
make it look the nicks as if things have
changed when nothing's really changed
maybe let's yeah see that junk over
there not good
but anyway Knicks
usually will you know if nothing's
changed it'll just be able to yeah here
we go
instant and we can actually run the
thing that we built okay
what's everyone's favorite verb sorry
jump okay that works so jump good
Chadwicks so that's how you use next to
build something now I want to configure
this as a service that I can run on a
server somewhere so this is the first
meter the next code that I'll show you
these are the arguments that are going
to be passed to the to this so this
essentially defines a function and these
are essentially this is very much like
dependency injection so config is like
the entire system configuration live is
the next library of helper functions
packages is every single package that is
known to nix packages annex packages is
a giant git repository of like every
package that Nixon was hard to build you
know that to build all this stuff to but
things kind of migrated towards that
giant gate repository it makes it really
convenient and Nix is a lazy on
dynamically typed functional programming
language which is why it doesn't
actually evaluate every single package
it only will evaluate what he cares
about and I'm what I want to do is I
wanted to find an attribute set so an
attribute set is Nix lingo for a
dictionary or a hash map or something
like that and it has two keys one is
options the options that I'm allowed to
set on the service and config the
generated configuration once I've set
those options so do that first thing I
want to do is I want to do the
programmatic equivalent of the next bill
that I just did and a for Nick's that's
couple of cool package so I'm gonna go
ahead and do that you can kind of
specify which set of packages you want
if you want to override the default but
I've just gone and done that for
completeness
so again options in config I haven't
like told you what those are just yet so
the option that I want is I want to have
an option to enable or disable the
service and again the next library of
helper functions gives me an option to
just make an option that
enabled will is yes and sorry true and
if it's false is no and if it's enabled
then I need to do something in my
generally config so I guess it's the
most complicated NYX particle in Xcode
I'm going to show you so what I want to
do is next one open a port in the
firewall unless I tell it to so I wanted
to open a port 3000 because the support
that I use in my example it also
generated a systemd service so system D
is a service manager you know it does a
whole lot of stuff but this if you have
written system D services or you'd
rather you know you're involved in that
stuff might look somewhat familiar it's
essentially a DSL so these are all
things that so a bit later I'll show you
that this actually you know turns into a
system D unit file but for now just yeah
this looks very similar system view
config and is this functional I'd argue
yes
it doesn't actually mutate any state in
your current directory except for that
symlink but you can easily remove if you
want your I'm declaring exactly what I
want and just letting the one come on
Nick's build make everything happen I
think that's pretty good
so let's ship it so I'm gonna get
another file called web server and I'm
gonna enable my service because that's
important so I'm just gonna go ahead and
I'm gonna go to a slightly different
directory so yep it's there I want to
create oh yeah so now I now that I've
created that file I can run this come on
to actually like take the the config
that I've done and output the every time
sorry I'm always like struggle with like
copying this line it's bit of a pain I'm
just gonna go ahead and do that oh no
yeah okay good so I can it's bigger and
I can actually so if you familiar with
system unit files I wasn't until you
know a couple years ago what it does is
that so one of the ways it makes
accomplish is what it accomplishes is
that it sets the path it controls what
the path environment variable is set to
and it kind of uses the inputs of
whatever you're building to determine
the hash of the outputs so it's very
much like it in that sense and this
extra bit here is for you know for my
benefit so it's specific specifies a
path and every yeah like I said you
inputs uniquely identify the outputs so
that works pretty well and this is just
a otherwise this is system D service
like any other service so okay so we've
that's what we done so far and now I
want to deploy it
so this files called shriveled Knicks
because I'm going to be using Nick's ops
and Nick's ops as a manual and this is a
trivial example in Nick's ops so I'm
gonna I don't think it's trivial but I
thought it was really good to like give
you something that you can refer back to
or link back to the official
documentation so so it looks like now I
want to deploy to VirtualBox because I
wasn't you know I didn't think wrangling
AWS would've been a good idea for a live
demo but anyway so I went to VirtualBox
VM I want you to be headless so I wanted
you I to pop up I wanted to have a gig
of ram and two virtual CPUs and I want
you to be running expect to be on Linux
so good then I can do a deployment so
I'm gonna be using Nick stops Nick stops
is a tool very much like popular share
for ansible but built on top of
everything that Nick's offers so I can
so you know just to show you that I've
got nothing you know in my sleeves I
don't have any deployments right now so
I'm going to create a deployment - D is
short for deployment - - deployment oh
sorry I will do that next
oh yeah create a deployment I'm gonna
deploy my deployment so it's going to
create a virtual watch machine attach a
distillate virtual machine and copy
everything that I care about
so that means my Haskell service and all
its dependencies and all its
dependencies dependencies so on and so
forth called it which is called the
transitive closure to this VirtualBox
virtual machine so the the the command
that actually does the the magic of like
copying everything over it's called
Nick's copy closure because it copies a
transitive closure of stuff over it's
really useful it's great
another thing that Nick's offers you is
that it gives you
binary caching so if you've built
something on a binary cache which is a
machine that's accessible to your
current machine by NICs then NICs will
actually query that binary cache before
trying to build something and if it's
already been built we'll just copy it
back down so very straightforward so
it's copying everything over you should
be pretty fast because it's just on my
local machine and as you can see the IP
address I'm not sure if you can is 192
168 56 and 1 101 so I guess the next
thing to do is to after this complete
successfully is to ask what your other
favorite verb is kill ok
don't know what you're doing your free
time but
hey that works so is this functional I
would argue yes I declared at least it's
declarative I said exactly what I wanted
I went to do virtual work spiritual
machine I went to this service on that
machine
make it happen NYX and it did so
excellent right we can all go home
develop this old forever except that
requirements change right this is a
reality of our lives as software
engineers so what's wrong with the
service that I sorry what's wrong with
this code can anyone does anyone notice
anything that jump-started them is being
extremely bad no okay sorry no I was
gonna say I'm hard coding the port here
who does that it's very bad so what this
means is because inside hard core to the
port I can't run two instances of the
service on the same machine if I ever
wants it to do that and I can't like run
something else on port 3000 if I want
you to do that as well so really like
this is not good enough right what I
want is I want to be able to specify the
port that I want and ideally I'd be able
to go back to the devs and be like hey
you hardcore is the port what are you
doing fix it please and they'll fix it
but in practice often you know
developers are working on something else
and you want this right now and they're
like too busy like working you know it
happens and lest you think this is a
contrived example like this definitely
happens with like all kinds of upstream
and downstream software even outside of
like the world of DevOps so it's really
important to be able to control every
aspect of the software engineering
yourself and NICs gives you that it
allows you to actually Patras the
package that you're building at any at
any stage so it's called so Nix builds
things in stages called yeah and this
there's a patch sorry phases is what it
calls them so there's a patch phase so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change the import to include this
Haskell function called get all eggs
which allows me to take command line
parameters or like arguments and I'm
going to change my previously hard-coded
port to get the command line arguments
and take the first one and that's the
new port
and you know you can just do essentially
arbitrary bash commands in the patch
phase so I'm going to go ahead and white
cap be the file that I'm patching just
to show you that it is in fact doing the
right thing so if I so if I do my next
build of patched
okay so you can see you did that in fact
do the patching that I wanted what you
know it's cool back up if I can yep so
you can see you've got the you know
Patrick correctly this should work
indeed it does so then I can
so now that I've patched it I want to
patch my service as well so the only
change I need to make well I need to
make more than one change here I need to
make sure that I'm importing my patched
package and I want to add an extra
option so that I can choose the port
that I want that will default to 3,000
so if not you know if I don't specify
anything additionally it'll just behave
the way it did before and I also need to
go ahead and when I'm running it past
the the port that I configured to it so
so going ahead and you know done that
and I want to import my patch service
instead of my previous one I unpacked
service so when you go ahead and go to
No
weird where did it go there you go okay
right so change that and all I have to
do is deploy again
Oh need a mistake what port do people
want I'm just gonna go to 2001 is that
okay with everyone
good it's done what's everyone's other
other favorite verb bill okay good
hey did it so another thing is you know
for for whatever reason I made a mistake
NIC's actually allows me next off slugs
means will actually list the generations
so I've made two deployments I did the
initial deployment and I did the patch
service as well
so if I for them under a reason I want
you to roll back I could totally do that
and as you can see they're not you have
to copy anything over because it still
had the old deployment on the on the
target so if I go ahead and do that and
other other other favorite verb deploy a
so yeah so in summary Nix
it's a package manager the programming
language to configure packages in that
package manager it's also build slash
environment tool mixer less I should
mention this earlier next class is the
operating system that's running on this
laptop and also on any target that next
ops provisions that's onyx ops works
it's an operating system built on Nick's
in the same way that you could think of
Debian is being built around app to get
you can't meaningfully separate app get
from Debian and expects to get something
that's meaningful meaningfully usable
mix ops the tool is very much like chef
puppet ansible etc built on top of Nix
OS it handles provisioning and
deployment in practice I would actually
not recommend using Nick's ops for just
because you could just use Nick's copy
closure it's not that much harder to use
Nick traffic closure yourself and do the
provisioning with a more full-featured
tool such as terraform but for a live
demo Nick's ops is perfect and you know
if you guys have a small deployment it's
it works just fine
so DevOps of Nick's is it automatic yeah
run one command it work
repeatable can I do the same thing on
100 machines yes speaking for experience
is it idempotent yes as you can see when
you know I nothing my input change my
rapid in change either is it reversible
yes I'd rolled back in front of you is
it atomic it does a lot of sibling
swapping so at the level of machine
sorry a level of a build yes and a level
of a service you I think you would
probably still want to have like a bunch
of machines behind the load balancer
and do some load balancer wrangling in
order to make sure that your user
doesn't actually see anything weird but
yeah but it does swap the same things
over at the system level as well as
functional yes I think so I said what I
wanted let the tool take care of the
details and it worked and thank you so
we do surprisingly have time for
questions I have a bunch of suggested
questions that you can ask or you could
just ask me something that's not on here
please feel free I will start here okay
the the question is how can you yeah
we're already wearing a mic I forgot
about that
the question is how do you use this with
SBT the scholar bill tool so Nick's
works best when you kind of give it
control over everything but another
thing you could do is you could just use
it to provision the dependencies that
you care about and drop you drop
yourself into a shell we can just draw
an SVG like you would otherwise and this
is something that I've done before so
that's how that's one way you use urban
SBT there are other ways to use it as
well but I'm not familiar with those yes
question is how do you deal with
database migrations and rollbacks that's
a really good question I don't really
see anything in nips mix-ups itself that
is geared towards that but it's I have
to think about that somewhere but there
other questions
am I missing anyone yes
yes oh yeah so the whole rollback thing
the benefit would use Nix OS over like
the reason you'd use an X OS over
something like Debian sorry I repeat
your question it's like it's Nick sauce
is Nick sauce do Nick sauce upgrades and
rollbacks work as easily as package
upgrades and roll backs - the answer is
yes you know that's what I do
I run Nick sauce and all my laptop's
works great yeah it's very so that the
nice thing about Nick service is that
it'll kind of keep previous generations
around until you garbage collect them so
if you decide that you're you want to
upgrade you can easily do that and if
you decide that your new upgrade is not
really working out for you can very
easily rollback works good yeah yes good
question so as you can see the the you
know the DevOps story that I told you
has no mentions of anything like
kubernetes or docker or anything like
that and one reason for that is that in
many cases you don't actually need any
of these tools to deploy your services
to a machine you know you can't just do
go at the level of system D right this
is gonna be service and expect it to
work another answer to your question but
to actually answer your question they're
not they're not necessarily in conflict
you can bake a docker image using Nix
Nix tools index packages so you don't
need you don't need doctor to make
docker images and you can run a docker
image that with that contains software
built and built by Nix so they're not
necessarily in conflict but if you
wanted to use one you know if you wanted
to use Nix by itself you can do that and
one reason you want to use this over
docker without having talked in your
stack at all is that this is a lot
faster than talker is so I mean I have
to do darker stuff stuff at work
sometimes but it's I was always very
very slow it's it's an ordeal each time
oh I should mention where I work so I
work at this company in New York
obsidian systems one reason I like
working there is can I good this slide
yes is that we're all in on Haskell and
Nix previously I worked at another
company doing DevOps with Nix which is
where I learned most of the stuff that
I'm telling you now and
yeah so but often we have clients who
want us to do darker things and I guess
will I find will do darker things but
it's not fun any other questions right
well I guess since we have got a couple
more minutes and uh does anyone to see
me make a change in real time to my
slides so I use docker to do my sorry
well I don't use docker I use Nix to do
my never I used next to do a CI CD thing
for my for my slides so I can make a
change and I used Travis to build and
deploy my changes so if I go to my
presentation
Oh so I mentioned binary cash on your
right so you can so there's a there
these two people who provide this
service called Kasich's so I can
actually go ahead and pre populate my
cash so Travis doesn't have to do any
building so
that's my personal Akashic sketch
they'll give you one for free for 10
gigabytes for open source stuff which my
presentations are ok so then I can do a
push we can go to my github and see this
happening in yeah there we go so it's my
presentations repo by the way my
presentation this this presentation is
available at my I don't know if y'all
can see that feel free to ask me for
links for the link to it later I have a
presentation repo I've hooked up my my
domain name to get uh pages so you
should be able to see
so I built finished in two minutes I
didn't actually have to oh that's
surprising
oh well then I should be able to go to I
guess there's something in my cache that
I didn't owe any my kiss Wellesley is
what sorry caching could be I'm not sure
oh no I didn't I don't push it
maybe I didn't push it no hmm tried to
live demo chat don't Travis CI probably
not a good idea anyway but the point is
that I have like my github repo and I
have you know Travis has some Knicks
integration so the step that actually
builds it so I just I just specify the
languages Knicks and it's I'm using my
binary caches and it'll all kind of
hooks up in works and um yeah cool yeah
if you if you use the same system for my
website for my blog for a bunch of other
stuff and if you're interested in
talking about any of this stuff please
come find me afterwards
I guess we're at lunch time so thank you
everyone
[Applause]